the only thing i have left is we didn't
ask you about bitcoin specifically you
got an end-of-year price prediction for
bitcoin
103.
i think there's a crazy run i think
there's a crazy run
um
i want to say it out loud say it say it
say it say it no no no no no so let let
me just say this um
there i think there is going to be very
large scale announcement from a
large-scale company
um and not and not not
somebody putting it on the balance sheet
even like i i
agree with you the two or three percent
from amazon would be de minimis for them
but massively impactful
um i actually think you're going to see
somebody accept this
that is going to surprise and open the
aperture of the usage of bitcoin before
the end of the year complex pays
employees in bitcoin
[Laughter]
that would be big time news john that's
a good one that would be first of all
i'd love to do it for my employees i
don't think many of them actually would
do it
yeah
would can you give us more in terms of
your thought process is there like an
industry or like why do you think it's
somebody accepting it would be such a
big deal
um
because i think i think like look it's
more of a strategic thing i think um
ethereum is a very interesting
you know coin in general in that it's
it's
usage
the more i've learned about nfts the
more i've learned about ethereum um
i think that the popularity
of bitcoin irrespective of some of the
technological limitations
i think there will be a provider a
platform and a sector
that is going to
finally transition
from a
um
to allow it to behave more like a
currency is my point
very interesting
uh i'm not trying to be vague i'm not
trying to be vague i i literally
it's there's
i've heard some rumblings of some very
interesting conversations my mind was
blown and i was like oh [ __ ] that would
really change the way
people would look at the limitations of
bitcoin more so than the possibilities
only i don't think anybody's debating
there's tons of possibilities but
everybody keeps going to the limitations
all the time right look at what you have
to stump for and overcome every day you
have to overcome as many limitations as
you actually do have to talk about the
possibilities could you imagine trying
to run a business that way that'd be
insane right so
i think if they if they're if the
community was smart
they would change some some of the
limitations and i think there's some
conversations going on there that could
be interesting
i'm not going to ask you to say more all
i'll say is people in the chat are like
oh he's got that inside alpha